Welcome,
my name is Barbara.
I'm the president of blue matter
project,
uft chapter.
On behalf of my team,
we thank you for deciding to spend your
night with us.
Our mission at the matter project has
been to provide the resources that we
believe would be beneficial to the
mental health of our fellow students at
u of c because a healthy mind is crucial
for success at this university and I
think we all know that maintaining such
as fade is no easy task.
I'm going to be asking you a few
questions and I hope that you
participate by simply raising your hand.
If the question applies to you,
how many of your currently undergraduate
students,
how many of you have had a radical
change in your core beliefs after
entering university?
How many of you have been reasonably
stressed out throughout your university
life?
How many of you have wondered at least
once in your life what the point of it
all is our confused about how you should
deal with the situation?
If most of these questions apply to you,
then you have at least I hope come to
the right place.
If they don't apply to you personally,
get some coffee with you on me to see
how the hell you do what you do,
just getting on Brooks,
so probably have to split the company.
The person who I have the honor of
introducing tonight that I considered
with significant influence on me,
I most likely on any of you who are also
familiar with his work.
If you don't believe me,
you can check the rate my prospect site
or did you have some comments on these
lectures you said you you will see the
words such as mind boggling and life
changing very frequently.
I was first introduced to him in the
first TEDX UFC event back in 2015 when I
was in my first year of study at UFT.
He was the first speaker at Tedx and the
title of his talk was potential as a
life science.
As students just finished a series of
courses in biology,
chemistry,
and mathematics.
I could immediately see that his
perspective on life was radically
different compared to the perspective of
other lecturers I had listened to
before.
As a result,
I found it difficult to connect with the
content of his talk at first,
but it was nevertheless interested in
his perspective.
Fast forward two years later,
Dan,
which I didn't hear any talk even
remotely similar to that are facing the
Tedx talk and I took a psychology course
called personality and its
transformations without initially
knowing that he was taught by him and
how fortunate I consider myself to have
decided to take that course.
This course,
along with his other course called maps
of meaning,
how far being among the select your
courses that I genuinely have enjoyed
trying to extent that I have watched
some victories over and over solely out
of interest.
I presume by now you're have your
constant.
What's the word?
Obsessed means?
Our speaker tonight has a bachelor of
arts in political science and a bachelor
of arts in psychology from the
University of Alberta.
He received his phd in clinical
psychology from Mcgill University.
He taught at Harvard University as an
assistant and an associate professor
from 1993 to 1998.
He then returned to Canada and took a
tenured position at the University of
Toronto and has been teaching here ever
since.
He's the author of maps of meaning,
the architecture of belief as more than
96 published articles,
he stocks are sincere and eloquence and
presenting content of unfathomable
depth.
He has attempted to present the forms of
untruth that we should both pay
attention and not fall prey to in order
to find truth and ultimately leaning,
leading a meaningful life.
I'm sure you are.
As excited as I am.
So we sent you to stock tonight and
without further ado,
please join me in welcoming Dr Peterson.
Thank you.
Thanks.
That was
one of the things that struck me
asking those questions is how many of
you have been,
you know,
pretty stressed out by your university
experience and I killed them.
Really.
Think,
how many of you were second year
students?
Okay.
How many are third year?
First Year of their.
They're too busy.
So.
So anyways,
that was the case when I was an
undergraduate.
I enjoyed my undergraduate degree and
um,
I went to a small place to begin with,
which was just a community college in
northern Alberta.
That was actually a huge advantage
because I had the small classes,
the big classes at 38 and the people who
were teaching there really liked to
teach and although they might not have
known as much as might conceivably be,
they were excellent teachers and they do
a lot more than me and that was
sufficient and so I really liked that.
I learned a lot in the first year that I
did in my entire school career prior to
that,
which is partly to do with me and partly
to do with the schools.
And then when I went to the University
of Alberta I,
it was less enjoyable because it got
more formulaic,
but I still have a good time.
I wouldn't say that I was stressed
particular,
you know what I mean?
No,
I wouldn't say that.
I would say I was probably less stressed
in the university that I was in.
High school pays better and I think that
that was.
I think that was probably the case for
most of my peers,
the people I knew with the score,
so you know,
things have changed since then and I
think
some of those changes put undue stress.
I mean the first is that your ability to
access careers of certainty has
declined.
Like for those of you who want to become
a clinical psychologist for example,
or who wants to go to medical school,
it's insanely difficult.
It's no wonder you're stressed.
My nephew tried to get into medical
school three years ago and I mean that
kids,
bright man I was watching him do those
is that online set of exercises that are
supposed to make you more intelligent
but the mosby and he was doing amazing
exercise where you have to maneuver his
way through a maze as well.
It was rotating.
You're treating them and that guy could
do that just like in the standing still.
It was really amazing.
We had a four point zero average from
queens and he had.
He was a like a really high level soccer
player and he was a,
he's a good guy,
you know,
he's the sort of person you just hate
because not only are they good at
everything,
they're actually great people
and a medical school.
What the hell?
He had 99th percentile and he couldn't
get into medical school.
I thought,
what the hell?
How stupid is that?
Because obviously that's a wasted
talent,
right?
It's obviously a waste of talent and
it's a betrayal as well,
people's because he hit the ball out of
the park on multiple dimensions and
still had to walk through three extra
two extra years of hoops.
He finally got into medical school,
but man,
he shouldn't be in a shoe in and by
getting into clinical psychology,
which is another one that I'm very
familiar with it,
you know,
I can tell you how to do it.
You have to have a higher grade point
average because otherwise you have to
have good gres.
In fact,
you probably have to have great juniors,
but then what you have to do is you have
to apply it everywhere because it's a
laundry.
So you have to apply to 30 place and so
remember that because it's a water and a
lot of these things are lot of reasons.
So what you do in the base rate of
rejection is extremely high.
It's first of all,
don't beat yourself up about it because
it's the base rate of rejection is
really high and you'll get rejected.
It has nothing to do with you,
the base rate taught and you really have
to learn that in life.
You know that the base rate of rejection
for most worthwhile things is like 95
percent and it's hitting I think in many
situations it's getting the odds against
you or actually increased.
Now there's some other positive things
about the way things are going.
You know what I mean?
Maybe you have access to the forms of
opportunities that would have been
unimaginable to me,
but a lot of those are also wanting to
monetize.
So that's,
that's an increasing problem,
especially if you're a creative person.
So,
so you know,
there's been this ramp up and
competition and it's partly because the
certain jobs,
as I said,
are difficult to obtain law laws the
same way and increasingly even having a
career as a lawyer is more risky than it
was say 20 years ago because a lot of
lies being nibbled to death by
technological transformation.
And of course journalism that's out to
most creative enterprises are out
because he can't monetize.
You guys also look forward to a job
career trajectory.
What are you going to be changing jobs
very often.
And so one of the things that I would
recommend is get used to that it good at
it.
Have you been CP it used to doing
interviews.
He ready to move at the drop of a hat
and keep your options open because a lot
of you in order to rush yourself up the
career ladder where to have to be
partners and you're going to have to
have options at hap.
And so whenever you're employed you
might want to be looking for other
opportunities that you can use as
bargaining chips so that you need to
transfer.
You know,
cross it up or you can use that as a
hammer to lap your employers on the
heads way because you're going to have
to be candy and tough and you know,
the upper end rewards insanely odd,
but it's a lot higher,
harder to climb into that category.
So I think that's part of the reason
that you're stressed,
you know,
is that your future is more variable and
more uncertain than people's future was
when I was in university.
So that would have been in,
in the early eighties and certainly much
more uncertain than people in the
sixties.
People's,
the people in the sixties,
their concern was that they were going
to graduate.
They have a job that would last the rest
of their life that would pay well and
know and then they're concerned with how
oppressive that was going to be.
No,
it looks pretty damn pathetic in
retrospect.
So,
but you guys don't have that worry.
So we're even with that.
So you know,
part of the reason I'm telling you,
because if your stress,
the first thing you gotta do is figure
out how much of that to you and how much
of it is situation because it isn't
necessarily going to make it less
stressful to know that it's situational,
but at least you could dispense with
some of the guilt and self criticism.
And also,
for example,
in publishing just for scientific
articles.
If you want to publish in a journal,
there's a one percent acceptance rate.
So you have to assume that you're going
to get it a lot
and the best things you ever get.
If you're trying to publish papers that
that paper really sucks.
But if you do a lot of work on it and
maybe rewrite it,
rewrite it completely and do a few more
studies of the same sort and they will
tend to really send it out for review.
And that's like time for a party.
And a lot of the things that you're
going to do in your life.
We're going to be like that.
Like they're very low probability events
and there'll be able to gradually.
But they are so you need to know that
because otherwise you will take
responsibility for that onto yourself
and normally taking responsibility is a
good thing,
but you want to take responsibility for
the things that you're responsible for
and you know,
parcel out external circumstances,
could they external work and so with
conscientious people and you know a
fairly large number of you are going to
be above average and conscientiousness
are,
you wouldn't have gotten to where you
are because you're above average in
intelligence and above average in
conscientiousness.
Is it conscientious?
People often feel guilty and also if
they're not doing as well as they
expected,
they automatically assume that there's
something wrong with them.
Now that can be a useful adaptive style
because generally if things aren't going
your way the way it changed this to
change things that you can control,
right?
So if you're thinking it's situational,
there's not much you can do about that.
And so sometimes there's utility in
focusing in on your micro path said I'm
all for that.
You know,
you got to take responsibility.
But it's easy for conscientious people
to take excess responsibility.
And so for example,
they do very badly if they're unemployed
and because they feel like losers,
you know,
and then they attributed that to
themselves and that can easily go too
far.
So the first thing is,
you know,
you have reason to be stressed.
Now another thing that's happened is no.
One of the things you might ask
yourself,
is it better to be a little a big fish
in a little pond,
little fish in a big pond.
And I would say generally speaking,
it's better to be a big fish in a little
point.
And you guys made a mistake by coming to
the University of Toronto on that
diminished.
And I saw this when I worked in schools
in the United States.
It was quite interesting watching the
students there.
So those were the Harvard students
because you know,
the diabetic students have a reputation
for being arrogant and I think that's
more or less something that's carried
over from the time,
you know,
schools we're really interested,
chronic,
you know,
and it was mostly based on economic
factors and familial connections.
It's not like that anymore.
The Saudi agreement.
The thing that was interesting about the
Harvard students is that they were the
top of the class wherever they were,
and maybe they get the smartest people
they knew and when they came to her and
they were,
they were in the middle for almost
everything in the bottom for some things
and the days of being the smartest
person in the room were seriously over
and so it was really hard,
you know,
but it was.
It was alluded to some degrees because
they were now with the non
representative sample of people and so
you're also with the non representative
sample of people and so average in a
high school is that's it's nothing if
you're thinking about it from an
actuarial perspective and a
probabilistic perspective than not.
There's nothing to be surprised about
and that's something else to keep in
mind.
Now,
the downside of course is that wherever
you go in your life,
what will happen is you keep quiet until
the people.
You're competing with her approximately
as good at things as you are,
and so that that performance tension
that you feel is something that probably
will never go away.
Hopefully you'll end up playing games
that are fair where if you work hard and
you do a good job,
that'll actually translated into
success,
but I suspect that that's going to be
the case.
The majority of you know,
because intelligence is a good predictor
of longterm outcome and so it's
conscientious.
People who can do things are rare,
really rare and one of the things you'll
find in the workplace is that if you can
do things and you're reliable and honest
and all those things and someone finally
notices that opened doors for you,
like math and that's something about
especially I would say especially
entrepreneurial enterprises that are
functioning well.
It's something that's underplaying when
they were described.
People who do a good job with things
almost always want to create
opportunities for other people who do a
good job at things.
It's actually a part of the.
If you're a successful,
one of the perks of being successful is
that you get to mentor young people have
opportunity and possibility and help
them and that's rewarding in and of
itself.
And all the people I know who are high
performing people who are powerful,
they all love doing that.
So know.
So there's places you're going to find
that are going to be relatively
inviting.
But having said all that,
you know,
there's a lot of uncertainty in the
future.
There's a lot of technological
transformation and it isn't obvious
what's going on in the future.
So,
so a lot of,
a lot of it's situational.
And then you know,
the other thing that's happened to some
degree is that there's an undue amount
of emphasis placed on let's say,
grades as the criteria that we'll select
you for the next level of attainment
because I think it starts to become a
mistake.
So I think people purely on the basis of
race,
once you're above about say a,
b plus or a minus,
something like that,
because people start to gerrymander
their education so that they increase
the probability that it'll get straight
a's.
And so they don't take the courses that
are interested in a course to still get
a's in logically,
so they twist and untangle their
interaction with the educational system
so that they get the output,
the system demands.
And I think that's really not good.
You know,
I think an optimal level academic record
is actually one where there's a fair bit
of high attainment with some outliers
now because it kind of indicates that
you're not obsessively focused on your
grades because you shouldn't be on
sensitively focused on them.
You should be focused on them.
And also maybe that you're willing to
take the chance to step outside of your
domain of comfort in hope of getting
educated.
But of course that isn't how it is.
So you're,
you're also stuck with that.
So I'm from a practical perspective,
I mean,
one of the things that I've done that
you guys could probably take advantage
of if you wanted to,
I'd be interested for a long time on
what interventions might help people
obtain the awkward in motivation to move
forward and the minimum of uncertainty
and stress.
And I could tell you some things that
you can engage in that are going to
help.
They're going to help optimize,
you're going to help optimize your life
and there's some exercises you can do.
This exercise called the future
authoring program,
which is online at [inaudible] dot com
and we've used that now with thousands
of university students,
mostly in Europe,
but we also just random Mohawk college
intro students at Mohawk college through
it,
and it raises their grade point average
25 percent drop out rate by about the
same.
And so what the future authoring program
does is help you.
It fills a niche in your education that
is pathologically underfilled for
reasons that I can't really quite
comprehend,
but I've looked into to some degree
which is,
and it's really the purpose of the
humanities,
which is I think in many ways speak for
God.
The issue is who the hell are you and
where you would go,
where are you going?
And then the subsidiary issues are why,
why are you doing that?
And those are not optional us,
like they're philosophical questions but
true philosophical questions.
They're not decoration on the business
of life.
There are the most fundamental possible
issues that you can grapple with and if
you don't grapple with them property,
you'll get flattened because you'll be
wheat and wheat means you won't be able
to express without falling apart and
life is full and stress.
And so if you can't tolerate it,
you'll fall apart and that's just not
good.
And so,
you know,
part of what you need to figure out is
what makes you
condition optimally in some sense for
battle.
It's not just that because it's also
cooperation,
but
you need both of those metaphors in
order to,
to consider the situation properly.
The future authoring program asks
people
to formulate a vision of themselves to
formulate an ideal for themselves.
And it's not a Nietzschean kind of
formulation under the things that need
to discuss when he was describing the
collapse of values first in western
civilization and then maybe around the
world,
the classic traditional balance.
So as that,
people would have to create their own
values as a replacement,
but it's,
uh,
it's too good.
It's an erroneous demand in some sense
because first of all,
you can't create.
You're smart enough and you don't live
long.
You have to rely on your culture
and second,
you just can't create your own values
because you can't cost yourself around.
You are a certain way who have certain
interests.
You had what prophylaxis.
You have certain inadequacies and
weaknesses that may be very tightly
aligned with your strengths is
complicated and so basically what you
have to do is discovered in some sense
what your values are and aligning
yourself with the property.
And so the future authoring program does
that basically asks you to envision.
Look,
one thing I've observed about people is
that part of the reason people don't get
what they want to do that and you're not
going to get something with it.
That's for sure,
and the more precisely targeted your
vision is and more clearly laid out what
you want is the higher the probability
that you're going to get it and it's
partly because you'll be moving ahead
like an organized and crystalline entity
and you'll be basically moving through
much because other people are much less
concerned about stopping you.
Then you are concerned about going
forward and so things will move away
from you and they do that quite
dramatically,
so it's.
It's a nontrivial,
a nontrivial utility to get your act
together,
point yourself in the proper direction.
The question might be,
well,
how do you do that?
And I've tried to think about that from
a practical perspective.
I mean the first thing is
what do you want,
and that doesn't mean it actually
doesn't mean what you want because when
people think that they can,
because we're in the theory of the
stick,
they tend to think about that in terms
of acquisition.
It's like,
what do you want for Christmas?
And that's it's understandable and it's
not wrong.
It's just second rate.
It isn't.
It isn't as good as it could be and it's
not good enough.
Really what you should be thinking about
is what sort of character you want to
have and the reason we want to think
about that is because your character is
your motive force forward and your armor
and if it's not well developed then
you're weak and you're going to get run
over and so you're.
The primary purpose of education is the
development of character and it's not.
It's not the sort of you should be like
this if you're a good person.
It's not prescriptive,
not if it's not.
If it's deep,
it's,
it's what are what,
what under what conditions would you be
willing to be satisfied with your life?
And this is a very important question
because it's not that easy to be
satisfied with your life and this is
partly where our education system leaves
people terribly astray because you know
the bone headed noise,
it's all about being happy and that is
not good because life is suffering.
It is.
And then having established that you can
say,
Oh yeah,
okay,
I get it.
I see.
That's why things are like this.
Then you can start thinking about what
you might do about that,
but if you start from the earliest
presupposition that the default
condition of human experiences,
happiness,
you're just done from the start because
every time you're unhappy,
you're going to think you're not going
to conclude that you're inadequate,
so you're not inadequate.
That's just how it is.
The question is how do you deal with
them and so we'll just say,
well,
you're destined to suffer.
You destined to lose your parents.
You're destined to be unhappy in your
career,
at least from time to time.
You're destined to fight with your
closest intimate friends and perhaps to
be divorced and have sick children and
could develop some sort of horrible
disease yourself and like there's a lot
of things coming forward at you and
Lauren have you are experienced those
things.
So like giving all that.
Why don't people are.
This was just hopeless.
There's nothing new about it,
but the problem is is that isn't going
to help and it's also gonna make it
worse and that's just the beginnings of
the problem because if you take that
attitude,
not only does it not help and make it
worse for you,
you will then turn and naked way worse
for other people,
and so that's just a nonstarter.
You don't go there.
That's inappropriate.
It's novelistic technically
and
nihilism leads directly to have as far
as I can tell,
and I mean that metaphysically and
technically so because not always is one
of the root causes of terrible social
psychopathology and societies can get so
far out of whack that they can do things
that are absolutely unimaginable and you
probably don't want to be part of that.
And if you do well then you should think
hard about exactly what you're doing
because there's something about it
that's corrupt.
So.
So forget about the nanoscale issue.
But the other thing that you shouldn't
do,
and this is another place where I think
our education system fails you,
is that you should not learn to parent
ideologies and almost everything that
students are taught as far as I can tell
now in the humanities,
is basically the paradigm of both the
head of the chiefs and there's ways of
identifying ideologies.
And one of them is it's always someone
else's fault that's one of the hallmarks
or it's society's fault.
And the other hallmark is everything
that's complex can be explained by one
principal because that's wrong.
It's just no one's sophisticated.
Everything stuff.
It's like you're looking at the card
isn't working and all you know is that
the fan belt might be loose.
And so no matter what the car is doing,
the reason is,
is the fan belts,
loops.
It's,
you're not going to fix the van,
the car,
because sometimes there's other things
that are wrong.
So any alarms over simplify and they're
very,
very rigid and they're also resentful.
And so.
And that's in some sense that's the
easiest alternative denialism right?
Because it's false certainty and it's,
it's,
it's rigid.
And the breakable and also takes you in
a terrible direction because if you're
rigidly,
if you originally identified with your
radiology,
anyone who challenges,
it's instantly your enemy
and
what you want to do with your enemies.
It's not pleasant.
So that's also not a very good route to
take if you're,
if you grab not end up in an absolutely
terrible place.
Okay.
So then you think,
well what are the alternatives to that?
That's where it gets hard because
sometimes it doesn't like there is much
of an alternative and it's like things
are pointless obviously because look at
all the suffering and the shortness of
life and all of that and nothing's
really turned.
So you have to take refuge in some
arbitrary set of rules and concepts and
you know like postmodern relativism
basically.
That's basically it's completion,
you know,
mind system and other system.
It doesn't really matter.
They're all predicated on power girl,
basically arbitrary.
And so there is nothing else there
that's not right.
It's seriously not running and it
shouldn't be taught to people.
I really think that's a bad thing.
I think it hurts people's mental health.
And actually I actually think that
that's the point,
so because malevolence is a motivator
and so his resentment and not everyone
is trying to make things better and lots
of people would rather have the misery
shared that hasn't disappeared.
Okay.
So then let's say potentially there's a
middle road and what is that?
Well,
I think some of it's empirical,
like there's this idea in behavioral
therapy of,
of collaborative empiricism.
And basically what happens is a person
comes into therapy and they say things
aren't going the way I would like them
to be,
which basically means I can't bear the
tragedy of my own life.
That's basically what that statement
piece.
And the therapist says,
okay,
well fair enough.
That's not so good.
You're willing to change obviously
because here you are.
How should you change?
And the answer is,
well,
we don't know.
So the first thing to do is find out and
so you go and then maybe ask the person
to watch their life for a the while and
see when things are going well and see
when things are not going well.
And that's,
that's not the same thing as creating
your own values,
right?
That's more a process of observation.
And so like I could say,
I noticed some exercises like this that
can be ridiculously powerful.
One of them is,
well,
watch when you're miserable and see if
you can figure out why,
but more importantly,
notice when you're not miserable and see
if you could figure out why.
Because at least in part what that
indicates is that you're in the right
place at the right time,
right?
Then that's when you shouldn't be.
Now where do you should be?
It's partly in time and partly in space,
right?
Because things progressed.
So you're always trying to locate
yourself in prime,
new space.
And now I'm in your nervous system
reports that all systems are go,
okay,
so that's a hit.
It's like,
okay,
I don't know,
I'm doing something right now.
And that seems to be working.
Now.
It's not,
it's not an a mississippian hint,
but it's a start.
Okay?
So then one thing you can think of is,
right,
let's see if I can figure out what those
places where I shouldn't be looked like.
And then let's see if I can start making
those places bigger and you know,
if you could make them one percent a
week,
if you do that for three years,
it's like they hold from maybe two
percent or five percent of your
experience to 85 percent of your
experience.
That's really useful.
So,
and that means humility,
you know,
that's actually a classical virtue.
Humility means you don't know what the
hell you're doing and you better pay
attention because you might learn
something and then you're training
ignorant even with regards to yourself
and.
But it also means that you treat
yourself with a certain respect because
it means all of a sudden that know the
autonomy of your own experience has a
real reality and it's an observable
reality.
And so,
you know,
people talk about this sometimes in
terms of the flow,
which is not a bad concept,
but basically what it means is that you
could find yourself engaged in business
in life.
It didn't matter that sufficiently
meaningful.
So the fact that life is tragic at that
moment,
that's not matter or maybe even better,
it's acceptable.
You know,
you might see this when you have
children,
if you're lucky,
and I think this is one of those
experiences where people get close to
that.
Children exposed the tragedy of life
like nothing else,
but if your relationship with them is
what it shouldn't be,
you think,
oh yeah,
that they're terribly vulnerable and
it's so worth it,
and that's what you want.
That's what you want.
You want to see your terribly vulnerable
and so is everyone you love and so it
was everything that you have around you,
but there's a way of comporting yourself
that makes that worthwhile and that's
what you're after.
And I would say that's actually the goal
of any genuine religious practice
because,
and the reason I'm I'm using the
religious example is because
if something is truly religious
significance,
what it means is that it deals with the
deepest elements of human existence.
By definition,
that's what it is.
If it isn't that it's not,
it's not in the category of religious
experience or knowledge.
So you need a path of being justifies
the suffering of life.
Then the next question is,
well,
can you find such a thing and the answer
that is you've got your whole life.
Find out and under the doing it,
that's the answer.
It really is the answer.
It's the prime question.
Can you conduct yourself in a way that
justifies the tragedy of the now in
order to do that?
Part of it is he can't be too arrogant,
man.
You can't think you know what you're
doing now.
If you're all happy and things are going
wonderfully and you have a perfect
relationship with being,
hey,
no problem,
but you guys don't put up your hands
when you said you're stressed out and
you know you're doubtful and you don't
know what's going on and you know,
so you're teetering between nihilism in
India,
logical possession and so you have a
problem.
Well that's a good thing to notice.
I have a problem.
Then you can know this.
Maybe I'm not correct because that would
be lovely if the reason that you have a
problem is because there are things you
don't know.
That's such a good deal because the
alternative is things are terrible
because they're terrible.
There's nothing you can do about it,
and then it's like not only were there
no bloody wonder,
so you could start with the possibility
that perhaps the reason that things
aren't as good as they could be or as
good as is necessary is that there are
fundamental things that you need to
observe and learn and change and then if
you really careful and sufficiently
terrified because that's also a
necessity.
If you're going to be sufficiently
careful,
maybe you can figure out how would
conduct yourself so that you get to be
strong enough so that you can tolerate
to tolerate that and maybe even more.
Maybe you could put yourself together so
that you're so strongly the other we
can.
You could say it's okay that things are
this way or maybe even that.
It's good that this girl,
so when I learned that in part by having
kids,
because kids are unbelievably
vulnerable,
you know,
and be really.
They're so cute and so perfect in a
certain way that there are
vulnerabilities also even more painful,
you know,
but you think about them and you think,
well,
let's,
let's eradicate some of that
vulnerability.
You cannot take a little three year old
and they're wandering around and you
know they're subject to any number of
potential catastrophes at any moment and
you think,
well,
you know,
you can enclose them in Styrofoam and
you then you could roll them down the
stairs and that wouldn't be a problem,
but then be enclosed.
It's powerful,
which is really what we're trying to do
with kids.
Or You could make them 20 feet tall and
making a buyer and then,
you know,
cars.
We've heard them all.
But the thing that's so strange is that
every step you take to,
to,
to eradicate the vulnerability is
simultaneously a step that would involve
the destruction of the person.
So that's so interesting because what it
means is that the vulnerabilities,
that central element of what it is that
you love,
that's pretty interesting because it
means that you could love something
that's truly vulnerable is something
that's,
you know,
that's susceptible to tragedy and it's
and it's mortal and fragile and all of
those things.
Okay?
So that's interesting because if you
love someone,
you make the judgment that their
existence is,
is good,
and that's cool because it shows that
well that happens to you spontaneously.
You can spontaneously make that
judgment.
You know,
maybe you could make that judgment about
yourself.
Now I don't think you can just,
you can't just do that.
That doesn't work.
People are like,
you can't really fool yourself,
and so you can learn to not judge
yourself with unnecessary harshness.
That's really useful.
And even learn to be compassionate with
yourself,
which basically means to treat yourself
as if you're someone who care about
because that's where true compassion
means.
And so you could modify to your,
your capital,
logical self criticism,
but in order to establish a positive
relationship with yourself,
you also have to respect yourself.
And I think to do that you have,
there's a bunch of things that go along
with that.
You have to be good for something good
for you.
That would be good.
Good for other people that'd be even
better,
good for other people in a crisis that
would even be better,
you know?
And so that way you can have some
respect for yourself because although
you're full of flaws and vulnerable,
you know,
if there's a storm coming,
you can still stand up in it.
And that's a good thing.
And No.
So I've observed people on surrounding a
deathbed,
let's say,
you know,
just it's easy thing for people to be
terrified of but doesn't help.
Like the person is dying.
You're in the room,
you're terrified and upset.
It's like,
Hey,
it's not your turn.
It's their turn.
And so hopefully when you're in that
situation,
you've got yourself together now so that
you're actually going to be helpful
then.
And then if you're not,
you know,
really terrible things happen.
So families often tear themselves apart
when you know a major part of the family
guys,
you know,
father and mother because there were so
mangled up in 15 different ways that,
well,
the tragedy is unfolding may turn on
each other like carnivorous wolves.
And so they take something that's just a
tragedy and they turned it into hale.
And I would say generally you can
tolerate tragedy,
but you cannot tolerate health.
So part of your life is part of what
you're doing in your life is to stop
tragedy from deteriorating into hell.
And if you can do that,
man,
like you're worth having around.
And that's actually grounds for some
self respect because that's hard.
It's really hard.
But consider the alternative,
you know,
it makes everything that's sad.
Absolutely unbearable in every possible
way.
You know?
And I've seen families who were coping
with the death say of a mother who were
courageous people.
You know,
there were people who had,
for example,
worked as palliative care nurses.
That's pretty tough for a man.
And you know what they did while their
mother was dying was held.
Yeah.
That makes the whole situation
different.
If it transforms the whole situation and
you know,
you just don't know how much your
situation can be transformed.
You don't know.
And you can take very terrible
situations that mean don't get me wrong.
Like I know what terrible situations
are,
like I'm not trying to offer you some
naive response,
but you can take situations that could
be honored imaginably pool and terrible
and you can transform them at least into
bearable tragedy.
And that's,
that's,
that's the transmutation that someone
with real character can manage.
And so those things are real.
You know,
a lot of what you hear about is about
the fragility of representations of the
world,
you know,
and about their arbitrary ness and
falseness that,
that there isn't that belief system in
some sense that is rotten to the core
and questionable.
And I think part of that is just because
it's the wrong questions that are being
asked.
Like if,
if the manner in which you addressed the
world makes you stronger,
then there was no.
That puts us beyond question,
if you want a question at that point,
and
even if you come up can come up with a
rational way of criticizing it because
you couldn't say,
well,
who cares how he wrote to you are on
your mother's death bed.
We need a trillion years.
You know,
all the stores have exploded in.
The galaxies are extinguished.
When I hear objections that anyone
parody,
that's such a stupid question,
like you're just missing the point
completely and it's a pathological
objection because you could say you're
one of the first soldiers that lays eyes
on Auschwitz and the first thing you say
is at,
it doesn't matter who's going to know in
a million years.
Sorry,
I get,
I get the rationale,
you know,
get the impeccable logic,
but it's,
it's,
it's the logic that only someone who's
corrupt beyond measure would dare to use
in a situation like that.
And so there's a simple way alternative
to that.
It's like if you're engaged in
something,
say that reduces suffering.
We'll just start with that and something
pops into your mind like who's really
going to carry in a million years?
The first thing you should conclude,
is that the wrong time for that thought
because you can criticize either thing,
right?
You can say that art is paramount and
the conclusion is irrefutable or
anything say anymore on any chattering,
devil can come up with that objection.
Why in the world would anyone with any
sense ever listened to it?
And that's a much more.
That's a deeper response.
It's an embodied response.
It's not a,
it's not a rational response.
There are deeper responses than rational
responses.
Their responses that involve your whole
being and those are the kind of
responses you're after.
You know,
because rationality,
it's a,
it's a states note and it's the highest
spirit and God's heavenly kingdom.
Yes it is.
It's the most powerful psychological
forest we have at our disposal
that you and it shouldn't be lost and if
it is you and it's awesome that it's not
good.
So.
So there's no reason to let that happen.
You can just,
you can just refer to your own
experience.
I mean there's other exercises and do.
This is a really good one.
This is terrifying though if you do it
right,
detach yourself from yourself.
So that's sort of a Buddhist faith
subset so you become a watcher of
yourself and so you have to watch
yourself like you don't know who you are
because you don't,
so you might as well do that.
And then
watch what happens when you taught,
kind of have to watch with your whole
body and notice that sometimes when you
say something,
you align and you come together,
you get stronger.
And sometimes when you say something,
you get weaker,
you fragmented,
and you know,
you could notice,
sometimes you'll get weaker if you say
something to impress someone you know,
you'll get weaker if you falsify your
own experience because you're trying to
manipulate the situation in order for
something to happen.
Um,
you'll get weak if act on it.
Act as if an intellectual principle is
something of your creation when it is,
you know,
because lots of great ideas you can't
really use unless you,
unless you've made them your own,
you know,
when we've had an attack to take
responsibility for them,
you have to be bought into because
otherwise you'd just chattering,
chattering
like a tape recorder.
You were chatting with tape recorder.
Nobody is crowded and you don't have the
right to know.
Um,
you'll notice sometimes this is a good
one.
You'll be involved in an argument with
someone and you'll feel stupid because
you're arguing.
Shut up there,
you know,
and that's often what will happen if you
do this
a whole bunch of very many occasions.
You just have to shut up because there's
nothing you could say that won't make
you feel weak.
And then you can start to feel yourself
around your words and you'll see that
here's something you could say,
your solidity hair,
you know,
it's like you're standing on a rock in
the middle of the swamp.
And if you deviate from that,
come apart and start,
feel weak.
And so we practice that.
You say,
all right,
I'm going to see what happens if I only
say things that make me feel strong
while you do that for five years and see
what happens,
and it's partly it's fleeting reference
to a very old idea.
It's an idea that's at the heart of
humanity,
which is that the idea that there's an
idea that conscious human interaction
with the ground with the va has
something to do with that.
It reveals it
conscious human interaction with the
ground of being is what makes potential
transformed into reality.
It's something like that.
It's an unbelievably powerful idea and I
believe it's.
I believe it's as true as anything can
be true.
That means to some degree that you speak
to yourself in the va and so that being
said,
if you want to make yourself strong,
you speak truth so that you could bring
yourself into being in truth and the
reason you want to do that because you
shouldn't be truthful.
Like in some sort of external,
external sense of being in accordance
with the traditional route rule.
Although if you really pay are real,
him is a lot better than just the AI.
It's more than that.
It's your attempt to construct yourself
into something that can react to the
manifestation manifestation of b
property.
That's true.
You're matching yourself to be and why
would you not want to do that?
You have to contend with it.
Who knows how powerful you can be.
If you contend property people can be so
powerful.
It's just unbelievable.
And you see this even in minor
for dinner with this guy a while back
and he,
he,
he'd been an athletic guy.
He a lot of biking qualifications,
that sort of thing.
He got hit by a car just wipe out,
so he's still recovering and he's.
He's pretty disabled,
pretty.
Went back to work.
He's aligned with mine.
It's a hard job,
right?
You've got to climb up power splice
cables together and you have to do it
under employment conditions because
that's been the standard,
the,
it's demanding and dangerous and all of
that,
and he's pretty screwed up because he
got hit by a car.
So he was telling me just just to casual
a story.
He was telling me about the last day
that he had worked and he was working
with somebody who his partner had
Parkinson's disease and really could use
one of his arms very well,
so I don't know.
He could use his left arm and the other
guy could use his right arm and so they
were on the ladder trying to fix this
and it's like,
no,
it just made my jaw drop because how
ridiculous is that?
He's not run over by a car and then this
other guy has Parkinson's disease,
which is just as miserable as clean as
you could hope to have nearly our their
ladder.
No freezing rain or fixing the power
lines.
It's like people can be unbelievably
tough,
you know.
And the other thing that you get
universities now that just drives me
crazy is it's like you can't be racist.
You can't say anything bad about black
people or Mexicans or white people or
Jews or whoever.
You can't do that.
But even expressed as much hatred for
the entire human race as you want.
And so that's just.
To me,
that's just like,
it's really bad if you only take one
sort of person,
but if you hate everyone,
well that just comes into your life.
You know,
you hear about this all the time.
We're screwing up the planet and the
planet will be better off if there were
people on it.
Then all this thing,
I think man,
never give the keys to the nuclear
arsenal to someone who thinks that way,
you know,
it's a despicable way of thinking and it
would be nice if we could develop some
respect for people.
I mean,
you know,
we,
we labor along under the burden that
exceeds the burden of anything we know.
We're the only creatures there are who
are conscious of their own vulnerability
and its ultimate vulnerability.
Man,
you're going to die.
That's where it talks out and look at,
here you are.
Now you're standing up,
you're in here learning.
You're trying to have a life.
You're maybe some of you are even trying
to be good.
That's a hell of a thing to do under
those conditions.
And so,
you know,
when you started thinking that way,
well first of all,
you can have a little more compassion
for people.
It's a little hard on the environment,
but it's understand it's role in
returning the favor,
you know,
I mean we're at war with mother nature,
but she's going to win,
you know,
we all die and we're doing our best to
protect ourselves from that.
And obviously there's some stupidity and
foolishness and you know,
malevolence and ravenous and this and
greed that goes along with that.
But asking someone to solve an
impossible problem perfectly,
it's like you're just the ultimate tired
when you demand that.
So you could think,
well,
we could give ourselves a bit of a break
and that's something to apply your
sending.
And I went to this thing at Queen's
university.
It was a tedx thing,
was so appalling.
If a professor came out and he was
supposed to be talking about these
computerized surfaces that he was
inventing,
which were pretty cool.
No,
but he came out and he went into a
tirade to the students about how they
should not reproduce because he said him
and his wife going limited themselves to
one child and I thought personally that
was one more child and he should've
passed.
No,
he didn't even notice that what he was
doing,
he was addressing a whole room full of
people like you who are just entering
into the,
into the beginnings up there,
up there,
truly adult life,
which is about children.
Is that what makes these adult and he's
telling them,
you are so despicable that you're tight,
shouldn't breed.
And then he thought that was more just
like,
what the hell?
I told him it was great horror because
really,
really nervous because I really don't
like doing that,
but you know,
I told him that I thought that what he
did was pathological beyond belief and
that she should be ashamed of
themselves,
but you know,
I freaked my wife out,
completely
panicked and he just hopped off the
stage saying that's what happens when
you talk about things.
It's like,
no,
that's what happens when you have
genocide in your soul.
That's not the same thing.
So you know,
hatred for humanity.
That's not a good thing man.
We know where that leads.
So why would say you could start having
a relationship to yourself and have a
little bit of respect for people can
older like mangled up and chewed up and
spit out and work in.
It's no wonder.
No.
One of the things I've noticed about
psychology is that we always get things
backwards.
Why did people manifest their abnormal
behavior?
Jesus,
a stupid question.
It's like,
what would you expect?
It's why people are ever normal about
anything.
That's step one in this history.
You know,
people come in to my office and we're
having a phobia.
I'm afraid that I,
if I go outside,
I might die and we'll get to the
hospital with todd having heart
palpitations and they're getting older.
I think.
Oh yeah,
that's not surprising.
You have tax surprises in it.
Like all the other 50 year olds don't
happen because of course what you were
afraid of and then you don't know with
the idea that the idea that it's a
mystery that people engage in abnormal,
no personality
mystery.
It's no mystery why people are afraid.
It's no mystery why people have low self
esteem,
which is a work by the way I hate and
why people are depressed and anxious and
in pain and confused and uncertain and
all those things.
It's like tap doesn't require any
explanation,
so if you were any of those things,
it's like so and then the issue is,
well,
what do you do about it?
You need to know.
You know how you would say your right
heel should be informed by your
knowledge of the greatest happiness of
the past because there's all that
knowledge city around your waist back.
Don't waste it,
use it,
and even ideal and ideal is a target and
it's a judge at the same time and it's a
motivator because you can be like that
and yeah,
as you move towards your ideal,
it will transform because otherwise it
wouldn't be anything to do.
Somebody's ideal will receive,
but we needed an ideal need to construct
it some sense or discovered ideal that
you believed in.
You have to inform that with your
knowledge of the past.
That's partly why you need to get
educated and that's why the humanities
are so important.
If the humanities still be universities
and they're going to go,
I think because
because they committed Harry Carey
fundamentally and of resentment as far
as I can tell,
and so it's really not good,
but the terror of it is that it deprives
you of what you mean.
You need to be able to extract from the
past the ideal and then you put that in
front of us about it and it has to be an
ideal that you believe is valuable.
You think,
look,
man,
if I could pull that off,
if I could do that,
if I could be that all this trouble
would be worthwhile,
and so we do this practically.
We say,
okay,
look,
three to five years in the future
because after that it gets kind of
blurry for France.
Who Do you want your friends to be?
Because you can pick your friends,
you know,
you can pick people who like you and
want the best for you.
That'd be good.
If you're willing to extend that
courtesy to yourself.
What do you want for your education?
Why do you think?
Let's talk about education.
What does it mean?
Here's what it means.
If you're educated,
you get your land,
which is great.
You know how to speak and you know how
to write.
If you know how to speak and write,
you are unstoppable.
That's why you're supposed to get
educated.
No one ever tells you that.
It's like,
well,
why are you running this so well?
It's a class assignment or maybe I'm
learning too,
right?
It's like,
why bother?
Why is that important?
It's hard.
Why bother?
Can write the reason you can't write.
It's because he can't think and again,
hey,
then you run into things and if you run
into things,
then your life is horrible.
So the reason that you get educated this
so that you can fake and not run into
horrible things and your life expanse
and it makes you powerful.
You know,
part of what I'm doing in my therapy
sessions all the time,
if someone comes in with a problem and
we articulate the problem fully and then
we can get rid of most of it because
once it's articulated to you can see
what's the problem and what isn't,
and then we can focus on a few key
things and make an articulate what a
solution would look like.
Then we can go war.
It's like,
okay,
this is the problem.
This is what you want.
How can you get it?
That's all articulation.
Here's strategy one,
strategy two.
Here's the rationales for all those
strategies.
Here's what you do.
If they fail,
you do that.
You do that.
Continuing things just move away and
front could be like they're not even
there because the people in like systems
that are stupid or stupid and weak,
otherwise he wouldn't be.
He wouldn't be stupid and weak if they
weren't stupid and weak.
And so if you're,
you know,
a straight Arrow,
let's say,
then that stuff just disappears in front
of you because there's no commitment to
it.
And language you're,
you want to be a master of language.
That's why you're getting educated.
That's why university.
And so I would say not only should you
not say anything,
it makes you weak.
You shouldn't write anything.
You don't believe I was talking to one
I,
my daughters
phrase this are great because I can't
drink coffee.
I actually hate it.
But for a drug that
might compromise with my own stupidity.
So
she was complaining about this sociology
class that she was taking half
Concordia.
I thought that was a sign for mental
health.
Yeah.
And then she said she had to wrote her
essay so that you know,
feed back to the professors with that
particular professor one of the year.
And so she was irritated about that.
Couldn't get me to do it,
to notice that the reason she couldn't
get motivated to do it was because she
had set herself up to the store for her,
her logos to just start her being in
order to please some person.
She had no respect for what's going on.
How could you be motivated to do that?
I said to her,
look,
you can't do that.
You can't do that.
You have to take your lumps.
You write the best essay you can.
He make it something you believe it and
if it doesn't fly,
tough luck for you,
but at least you haven't corrupted your
character and she's sort of my door.
Well,
can you just don't understand how the
university has changed?
That's
maybe true,
but it's not relevant.
The problem is is once you write
something you believe,
if you can't tell them the data,
and that's actually.
If you can come here and let's say
you're a radical left wing or on some
viewpoint or radical wreck when you're,
it doesn't matter,
and then I say,
okay,
you have to write an essay countering
that position.
Now,
to renew in a week later,
you shifted weight close to your
argument,
and the reason is is that the belief you
have to begin with is shallow.
You've never really articulated it.
You just have it.
It's like a heuristic.
It's probably based on your temperature.
You articulated revival,
you have a weighting or a well developed
argument for the repellent they need to
do for the original proposition so you
ship,
so every time you write something to
please someone,
then you're damaging your character.
You might say,
well,
who cares?
Like the honest dope Friday anyways,
which is wrong.
By the way,
that's what you've got is your
character,
because nothing else will defend you
against suffering.
That's what you've got.
So you sacrifice that,
you sacrifice it everything.
And it's worse than that because once
you sacrifice that,
you get weak and when you get weak,
the tragedy mouth and as the tragedy
mouse,
you get resentful and then you get cruel
and they get vicious and there's no
stopping.
And that's just the beginning.
I mean there's no end to the downside
with that and like we already saw in the
20th century what happens when people do
that.
It's not good and all of those deaths
should have taught us a lesson and the
lesson is don't do that.
It leads to it least the worst possible
situation that you could imagine.
No matter how well you can imagine
impossible situations and maybe you want
to partake in that maybe don't,
and in fact maybe you do not want to
partake in it.
You want to do exactly whatever is
necessary to decrease the probability
that that will happen and we know it can
happen and we know it doesn't have to,
and so obviously there must be things
that you could do to ensure that doesn't
happen,
so those things are hard to discover.
You know,
it's easier to see where something is
wrong than where it isn't wrong.
It's just simpler.
But,
and I think that's very tightly aligned,
you'll find that stereotype type in your
life at the same set of phenomena that
you will discover.
If you know this day to day,
week to week,
month to month,
what makes you weak and what makes it
meaningful,
so weakness.
If you speak in a way that makes you
weak,
you'll be curated into that domain.
If you don't and you watch what makes
your life meaningful,
then you'll get stronger and stronger
and we get farther and farther away from
that and you'll be more and more likely
to manifest yourself in a way that makes
those things less and less likely.
And you know,
even like,
here's a,
here's the proposition for nihilists.
It's,
I think these are good propositions.
Okay?
Argue yourself out of pe.
Oh look,
you can't do it well so much.
The deliberate steer rationality,
and this isn't the things that are maybe
less because there's pain and that's a
form of meaning.
It's not a form of media you want,
but it's there and you can't argue
yourself out of it.
So the next thing you might say,
well,
how about a little less pain?
How would that be?
And then you say,
well,
what difference has been made?
It's like get away from that person
because I think some things are self
evident.
Don't torture kittens to death,
but who's going to care in a million
years?
It's the wrong level of analysis,
so that's just a trick of the rational
mind so you don't play along with that.
You notice and that's upsetting.
That's horrible.
That's terrible.
I don't want to go anywhere near that.
Great.
Don't go anywhere near it.
That would be a good thing.
And so you can start by avoiding.
That's the way to bring meaning into
your life.
You start by avoiding hell
and then if you're lucky you,
well,
if you avoided enough,
then maybe you can start thinking about
how you might,
you know,
climate stairway to heaven,
but the first is the first is the first
because it's really easy to believe in
pain and so all you have to notice is
that you believe in and that maybe you'd
rather not have any more of it than
necessary.
And perhaps that that would also be good
for other people.
Hey,
that gives you a starting point
and once you have the starting point,
it's like our communities.
He said,
you know,
if you gave them a lever and the proper
fulcrum,
you could move the world.
Well,
as far as I can tell,
that piece of knowledge is precisely
that because I don't think he couldn't.
You can't dismiss it,
not without in instantaneously
establishing yourself as an agent of
malevolence so,
so
that's that.
So I would say you Orient Yourself,
you Orient Yourself,
you have to do that.
You have to Orient Yourself towards an
ideal and you'll have to dinner out with
your ideal is you can figure out what
your ideal is by noticing who you
admire,
because the phenomena of aberration is
the attempt of your psyche to construct
an ideal that you can fall and it's
involuntary,
which is another thing that's
interesting to notice,
right?
It's like you don't pick who you admire,
it just manifests itself and so it's an
unconscious manifestation of your
psyche.
Or You could say it's a revelation of
Ba.
It's the same basic idea,
and so you think,
well,
I fire this person.
Okay,
well now it's like day.
There's an ideal nest in that.
What is it that you want for match?
What is it you want to derive from that
and you derive that and then ride the
old ship and so it's a moving target in
some sense,
but it's well worth following.
So and again,
it's nothing that you can rationally
undermined as far as I can tell any more
than you can rationally on your mind,
being in love with someone you know,
being trapped,
being in love with someone either can't
control it so you can accept it as an
existential Faq and then you can work
forward on that basis.
So then I would say,
well,
part of the ideals Orient Yourself
towards the improvement of being.
So the idea is,
and it can be vague because what the
hell do you know?
But the issue is you've got to decide
you want things to be worse or do you
want them to be better?
That's the first decision.
And you might say,
well obviously one of the things to be
better,
it's like don't,
don't be thinking that's obvious because
it's not.
And people are always working to make
things worse.
And there's a part of everyone that
works to make things worse.
So if you think that that's not part of
you,
then you're not even in the game yet
because you,
because you're naive fundamentally and
you're going to get walloped and walt
enough,
you won't be dying and then you'll start
seeing this and that will be painful.
So it'd be better just to circumvent
that completely.
You could.
So you think,
well,
how am I going to make things worse?
I'm going to make them better.
Well,
what's works?
Milo?
Milo is China.
That was bad Soviet Union.
That was fat Nazi Germany.
That was bad.
Let's not go there.
Okay?
So we thought how great things were.
Staff,
we get away from that.
How to make things better.
Comfort question.
At least stop making the worse you.
And then I would say,
you know,
one of the,
the other exercise that I think is very
useful apart from watching your speech
and don't write things you don't believe
now that is really dangerous.
It's,
you're working your character and once
you do that,
it's very difficult to get to work stuff
because you actually rewiring yourself,
writing does that.
You're changing your memory structures.
Would you?
Right.
So I think that's even more indication
when you,
when you see the same thing happens with
you speak,
the next thing is in part,
notice what you could make better,
you would make better,
and then make it better because you
might say,
well,
I don't know what's good,
what's not good.
So that's a start.
That's really useful.
That doesn't.
Just because you specify the end one end
of a continuum,
it doesn't mean you necessarily specify
know.
So it's fuzzy.
What's the opposite of being a Nazi?
Well,
we don't really know.
We don't know exactly,
but you get glimmers and I think that's
the right way of thinking about it.
There are things that glimmer glimmer is
this is right and I can fix it.
And then it's like,
you know,
it's not right.
You don't have to question.
These are grandiose states.
These are small things.
They're really,
they're small things like,
um,
there's,
there's some things I should attend to
today.
Little tasks,
you know,
things that you know,
that if you don't do your life will be
worse at the end of the day.
Then it was at the beginning who enough
and some of those things you might say,
well,
I'm not going to do those and okay fine,
or I don't know why,
but some of them will be the things that
you could do that,
you know you should do them.
They're little things,
they're little things,
but if you do 100,000 of those states
and everything will get pristine and
beautiful around you and that makes life
a lot more bearable and then you can
kind of start distributing that around
and that's really,
really helpful.
It's really helpful.
So,
so he need to know where you're going
and hopefully up rather than down.
And if you've got desire for doubt in
you then
well then the first stream to do is
notice at least to know that that's the
case.
If people are very destructive,
you know,
and they will hurt and they need to
destroy it and so that's part of you and
you have to.
You have to grapple with that and you
have to decide if that's what you want.
I would say
that's all there is to it.
You have to decide if that's what you
want.
What does you notice?
What did you decide that and you tried
it or anything so that and start
watching,
watching what makes you strong,
what makes you.
We'd do the things that make you strong.
He stopped doing the things that make
you wait and while you're doing that,
try to make things better.
Now,
not in a grandiose way because what the
hell do you know if you don't want us to
fix everything because you're just
screwed up.
You want to fix a few things around that
are within your realm of competence that
you know absolutely that you could make
better.
Now you might not move.
Why?
It doesn't matter.
You have the confidence.
You know how to do it.
A child comes up in their car or maybe
they tell down,
you give them a hug and pat them on the
head and you know that works.
It works.
Okay,
so that's something that you're
competent to do,
so that's the right thing to do in that
situation.
You know
you don't have a discussion about that
because it's already established and
there's lots of things that you guys
already know that are like that,
so you do that micro steps and sunsets
and then you stand back and you have
some faith and faith is the willingness
to try that to see little while that's
all because there's no proof like,
I can tell you about this but I can't
prove it within the confines of your own
experience,
and so you have to manage faith that
things could possibly be right
and that's an act of courage and then
the things around you sort themselves
out and hopefully they sort themselves
out for you in a way that also sorts
them out for other people and then
things get better and maybe as they get
better,
we won't be so concerned about how
horrible things are because you've got
to say was so bloody creative and
amazing.
If everybody on the planet was like
laying things out as fast and hard as
they can,
man,
we'd solve every problem.
There is no time flat.
So
seems like a good deal for beats
complaining about how miserable,
wretched and destructive human beings
are.
No,
it's not good.
It's not good.
It's not a sign of ethics to do that.
It's quite the contrary.
So
I have to save all of that.
So we're going to have questions.
Right?
Okay.
Thank
you.
What I'm going to do,
I'm going to answer questions that I
haven't answered the question.
It's either because
I'm too tired or I can't formulate
reasonable as
morally right to bring people into
existence without consent and knowing
that they will inevitably injured or
suffering during their life.
Isn't it selfish?
Good question.
Um,
tolstoy asked that question in his
confessions.
So if you're interested in an answer to
that question,
one of the things I would recommend you
read that book because that was Kinda
historically should be looked at life.
And he taught
and he tells this story.
It's a story about this guy in the field
and he's being chased by people who want
to kill him.
So he jumps into this hole and he's
hanging on.
It's like an old.
Well,
he's hanging on for dear life is
scratching and at the bottom of the hole
there's a crocodile and so he's heading
on there will always had you gone.
He noticed there's two things.
There's some grapes on the vine and then
there's about two nice ones,
the black mouths and one's white Nelson
and they're on either side if the and
they're chewing through it so he knows
he can get out and detail.
Taylor,
you can fall and get killed or he could
wait.
So what do you guys eat?
The grapes and it's a Buddhist story
that was story because the white mouse
is chaos or order in a black house is
chaos and there's always things working
at the of being.
There's no doubt about it and you know
you're screwed no matter what you do,
which is the moral of that story.
I told a story,
looked at that story and said,
look,
the only logical conclusion that you can
draw from that is that life is so
terrible that it shouldn't exist,
and hey,
dusty dsts the same question in probably
just chromosome.
You have this character named Ivan.
It was a smart goodwill being tough guy,
good intellect,
perceptive,
and he has this revenue down the Osha
who's kind of.
He's a soft diet in some ways.
He's not an intellect,
but it was really a good person.
Now the just kind of classically
religious and he's.
He wants to be a novitiate in the
monastery and I just to bed because he
can blow over with his intellect,
you know,
and I can tell us the story about the
Gospel.
He took the newspaper,
this family,
mother and father,
they were angry at their four year old
daughter and a locked her house
overnight and she was screaming out
there and she froze to death.
It was news and in Moscow,
and I can basically says to Leo should
know who's making the case for the
goodness of being of the goodness of
God.
Anyhow,
you want to look at it,
and I've been so you bothered,
how can you even dare to make $9 like
that?
It's like
this is the sort of thing that happens
in the brain all the time,
and then you ask somebody,
oh,
should look when you be willing,
voluntary departure,
that girl to death to ensure that things
would continue.
Well,
no,
I what I know you wouldn't do it.
So it's like,
what's your conclusion about that being
shouldn't exist?
And then that asks the same question in
a firehouse is character in that have
met the software,
these,
this.
He's kind of the intellectual ankle of
statement.
That's one way of thinking about it
and he says the same thing.
He's talking about his motivations.
He says,
well,
what motivates the great adversary of
mankind?
And if it says it's straightforward,
being so terrible that it should be
eradicated.
Okay,
fair enough.
Strong
people try it.
It's not clear to me that that's where
we should go.
So because as far as I can tell,
when people work for the eradication of
being,
it makes everything that they're
complaining about way,
worst,
really fast.
And so then the other thing you might
ask yourself is,
do you think that's the motivation?
It's really so purehearted no,
they're going to destroy mankind to save
and then making a judgment.
The judgment is being is so terrible
that it shouldn't do exist.
Now,
don't get me wrong.
I get the rationale for that is either
his rationale.
It was never put more strongly than in
the brothers Karamazov.
It's a famous passage and writing.
So
the question here was with regards to
bringing children into the world.
Well,
it's a variation of the same question.
No,
the question is what do you have to
conclude if you're not going to do it,
you're completely with but is not with
the being is not justifiable.
Well,
that's a hell of a conclusion.
I would be very careful before I made it
because there are places it takes you
that a not good.
So.
And then you might also ask yourself,
are you so sure that you're asking that
question just because you're a good
person or you maybe asking that question
because you don't want to say of having
a child in his finger and said are maybe
you're afraid that you won't know how to
fortify the child property.
So you're withdrawing fair,
fair enough.
Look,
what do you do with children?
Does you encouraged them?
And I mean that literally it's like a
little kid and he'd say,
look man,
you can take on the world.
And you don't sugarcoat it just like
it's not.
It's all
fairy tales and roses.
It's not the old Sheila is.
She opens enough so you don't damage
them.
It's a really tight because you don't
want to know why overwhelmed someone
hurt them while you're teaching them.
You have to expose him gradually and
with intelligence,
you do that by having a relationship
with a kid.
You don't want to shield them from
existence.
We want to show them just what it's like
and then you want to tell them it
doesn't matter,
man,
you're tough enough.
You can do it and you can do it right
and it's true.
It can.
And if you,
if you fortify them with that knowledge
matter are,
they're being is not characterized by
the kind of suffering that makes
existence intolerable.
And so the answer is not to have
children.
The answer is
cooperative and encourage them,
and that's tough because you don't.
You're kind of fragment had been broken
and if you treat your child right,
they might exceed me and that's
annoying,
so you made you everything.
You can bloody well made sure that your
kid is broken enough so there's no way
they're going to do it any better than
you,
and so I wouldn't recommend that,
but people do it all the time,
but that doesn't mean that existence
itself is insufficient.
It just means that you're not handling
the property and you're making it far
worse than it has been.
One of the things I asked myself a long
time ago,
first of all,
I know there's a distinction between
tragedy and that's an important
distinction.
Tragedy is when things happen that
aren't good,
someone gets canceled.
No,
I'm your child slips and breaks his or
her leg.
You know your parents die.
That's true.
Evil is when something tragic happens
because someone wanted to tap.
Okay,
so we can distinguish between your
students.
The first thing I would say is people
can have a tragedy like you can get
tough enough so you can have.
In fact,
I think you can get tough enough so that
you even get tougher if you're exposed
to trash.
That sort of statement about,
you know,
whatever doesn't kill me,
makes me stronger.
Obviously itself,
it's an overstatement.
It's very hard for people to tolerate
evil level ones.
So like I've seen people,
for example,
because that adolescent clients with
posttraumatic stress disorder there very
often traumatized by malevolence,
not trashy.
They fall victim to someone who wants to
hurt and maybe it's even been self that
wants to hurt them and that's revealed
to them,
you know,
but sometimes it's that they come into
their often naive people,
they come into contact with someone
whose purpose is to hurt them and that
shadows so badly they can't put
themselves back together.
Evils really devastating.
I think human beings can tolerate
tragedy and I also think that if people
oriented themselves towards the
improvement of being,
we could continually ameliorate tragedy.
And I do also believe that being a
striving to perfect itself.
Now that's obviously a metaphysical
statement,
but I don't really care if it's a
medical metaphysical statement.
I have my reasons for for bleeding and I
think that the purpose of human life is
to participate in that process and
because again,
the alternatives,
things are quite list and life is
suffering and it should be eradicated.
It's like that leads nowhere.
Good really leads nowhere.
Good,
so I can dispense with it.
It's better tasting.
It's like a bad roadmap because most
profound it is our roadmap.
They tell you how to get from one point
to another.
You know,
if you want to get to the depths of
infernal chaos or do you want to move
towards something that approximates
paradise,
well,
he'd better make sure you have the right
map and so and most belief systems,
our roadmaps,
they're descriptions of reality
description,
objective reality.
There
are so have kids say it's one third of
your life,
you will bloody won't regret it.
If you don't do it.
You're not going to make 20 or 30.
Some days you're going to be 50 or 55
and maybe it will be alone.
That's not so good and so you're a fool
if you don't have kids.
Now,
I mean,
I know people have their reasons and
some people have appropriate reasons and
all that,
but if somebody ideological hang up that
stopping you,
Ms Dot Donna,
you better dispense with that instead
instead of dispensing with the kids.
Is there a book you could consider
essential reading?
Oh yeah.
You have to ask that because after all
you are at university,
you should read Dostoyevsky's five
grades.
They're unparalleled.
So that's notes from underground crime
and punishment.
The possessor of the devils,
it depends on the translation.
The brothers grounds off the idiot.
There's also one called the adolescence,
so I missed there sits,
so any of Dostoyevsky's great novels.
They're not.
You can't not read their key pieces in
the.
In the psychology of I'm
Solzhenitsyn's Gulag archipelago.
That's a nature book.
Math and that's the description of his
experiences inside the prison camps and
that book helped bring down the Soviet
Union.
It destroyed the intellectual and moral
credibility of communism.
It was an atom bomb,
that thing and he memorized it 2,700
pages long,
so it's hard to manage because it's
nothing but atrocity in terror,
but there's.
There's no shying away,
you know,
like,
and this is one thing that I really like
about it most of the time,
like the novels or intellectual or moral
doubts,
that's a better way of thinking about
it.
And you know,
most of the time when you hear people
have an argument,
they do tricks.
Like let's say you and I are going to
happen on argument about something,
the first thing I'm going to do is
listen to what you say and then I'm
going to create a stupid form of it and
then I'm going to destroy that stupid
form.
And when you try to object,
I'm going to into Robert.
No,
that's the,
that's the straw man argument,
right?
What I should be doing is I shouldn't be
listening to and if you're not very good
at formulating your arguments,
I should help you formulate them.
So they come out as clearly as they
possibly can and then we should have a
discussion to see where we go.
And that's what does doc does.
He takes like his.
He was an Orthodox Christian and Russian
Orthodox Christian,
his atheists man,
those are deadly atheists.
You know,
they make it's look like a piker.
Dorsey esd takes Ivan is a really good
example.
That guy saw everything going for him.
He's really good looking.
He's really strong.
He's your courageous like he's sharp,
he's admirable,
he's fearless.
He's a major contender and he formulates
arguments in favor of atheism that are
almost.
They're almost,
in fact,
our actually cannot write your rejoinder
while he does instead is he.
He plays out the consequences of the
ideas,
you know as the characteristics and he
takes his other characters like that who
don't adopt that way of being and then
plays that out and shows them what the
consequences are,
which is brilliant.
It's like if you read brothers Karamazov
and then the possessed with the devil,
and then you read who let her go,
you have the perfect merging of literary
or veterans
literature.
You have the perfect marriage of
literature and history because what
Dostoevsky says will happen and why it
happens is exactly what happens.
So it's just fun.
Broken sequence of moral revelation.
So Nike camp under you can hardly
overestimate the impact of soldier nets
is for.
First of all,
we wanted to know the price for it,
but more importantly he did more than
over.
Took out a tarion communism.
Then the American,
the American military.
No,
no.
I'm not saying necessarily that the
American military was a major player.
That boy,
I certainly think they work because
Stalin was perfectly willing to drop
into Europe with hydrogen bonds.
You know,
he's a seriously.
He was seriously not a good guy.
So
when.
Okay.
So those like,
those are absolutely necessary books.
Most books written by people who are
universally regarded as great.
This
here,
you know,
you hear this again on the edges of
literary criticism said the canonical
writings were selected because of the
desires of the oppressive class or some
sort of absolute rubbish like that.
It's like
partly,
but it's not relevant because all these
people like pages and pages full of
derogatory comments about women know
they're not full of them,
but they happen now.
Well,
who's writing by yourself?
He was really,
really sick.
Never sold any books.
He was so ill,
he could hardly write it.
All confined is reading.
Took like 10 minute bursts and he was
isolated and alone,
so now I'm tired to resentful and wrote
something rude.
The guy had his off time.
He,
Darlene was like for me.
You know what I mean?
He was a genius.
He was a full professor when he was here
as John.
It's like,
you know,
it's not pleasant,
but what you're supposed to do when you
read a grit work is
from the.
We know we're not supposed to noticed
one stupid thing and say,
oh,
the whole thing is rocking.
That's as fast.
Really.
That's faster.
Here's so pathetic.
If you do that,
you know when you read Freud and like,
yeah,
he wrote in the 80 90 [inaudible] and
some of his ideas are outdated,
but what do you expect?
The 80,
what do you expect?
It's like,
so you say,
well you have to discard 20 percent of
it and you pulled in the other 80
percent of your bloody lucky that the 80
percent is there.
You're supposed to be reading not to get
rid of things,
but you take the things that are
valuable.
And so I would say,
you know,
I learned a lot from reading Freud,
I learned a lot,
a tremendous amount from reading your
bio is so profound that it's through
unspeakable.
It's no wonder they don't teach it in
universities like I'm serious,
man,
that guy was,
he was a whole different form of life.
So he's terrifying you only as the
person who will convince you that there
are things going on in your head that
have nothing to do with you.
And that is not
a very,
that isn't one of those things that's
designed to make you sleep easily.
At night.
Rogers,
I learned a lot from Carl Rogers,
like all the great clinicians,
they already have something to say and,
and practical to say that will help you
live your life.
George Orwell,
Elvis,
Huxley.
Um,
well that's not that start.
But like,
if it's part of the Canon,
this,
especially the literary Canon,
you can assume that there's something to
it.
And if you could also assume that if you
read it and you don't get it,
it's probably you.
So fucking.
So that's what does forgiving yourself
look like?
That's a good one,
but I'm not going to answer it.
What's the best strategy?
Can help people
get your act together,
lead by example,
and then if somebody comes and asks you
for your opinion,
tell them the truth.
That's.
That's one thing I never liked someone
listen,
psychological trouble.
You'll just make it worse,
especially if they're of on the
schizophrenia ends up things do not lie
to them because they're very clinging to
the reality as it is and if you,
you know,
they're already courtney structured in
some sense he dropped a little bit more
sensitive to that,
you know,
and it's hard to tell the truth.
It's,
it's tricky because you have to be
telling the truth sort of at all levels
at the same time.
And also it has to be reworded.
It has to be right.
The phrase has to be right in the
semester.
We write paragraphs to be right.
The dialogue between the two of us to be
right,
you have to be oriented in the right
direction.
Like all of those things have to be
happening at the same time for it to be
true,
because otherwise you could say
something that's destructive just so
that you know,
filled the demands of the darkest part
of your being and then you can say,
well was true.
It's like,
no,
it wasn't.
It was true.
I had one tiny level of analysis and
what you're doing is usually off the
street to demonstrate your moral
superiority would actually interacting
in a Mrs. Steve messed up
bad.
So
listening is really useful too.
That's great.
So you mentioned that part of us wants
to make things worse.
What exactly do you mean?
Is there anybody here in this room who's
actually never wanted to hurt someone?
Look,
people
look deeper.
How about yourself?
It's okay.
You don't have to answer that.
The reason that there are people,
one make things worse fundamentally is
because they get irritated that the
structure of being,
you know,
we get tortured by da because this
soccer and then they get resentful and
angry and then they want to take it out
on someone.
You know,
when you really see that,
you know,
the US has an epidemic of mass shootings
were happening so often I need to record
them,
was doing that resentful people who want
to make things worse and they're people,
they're like,
you know exactly like you,
but they're quite a bit like you.
And so if you can't imagine what they're
doing and why that.
Well,
one thing I would say is you don't know
very much about yourself and you're
actually not watching very carefully
because I mean I think I might have a
darker side,
but most people,
I mean be inclined to believe that from
time to time.
Oh,
I'm not sure if it's true,
but if you watch yourself,
you can see how you want to hurt all the
time.
It happens.
I bet it happens 50 times a week.
You know,
you want to win an argument with someone
you love.
That's a good example.
You don't listen,
you're not trying to solve the problem.
You just want to win an argument.
Well that's not very helpful.
It makes things worse.
So,
and this isn't my opinion,
although it is my opinion,
I mean one of the oldest stories,
you know,
there's a few very old stories of
mankind and one of them is that there's
a battle between good and evil going on
in the human soul.
And that's exactly right.
As right as people can make as it's as
right as people can state it,
you don't,
you might say,
well,
you know how you define good
Auschwitz.
We don't have to have that discussion
anymore.
I'd like to know a bit about your
personal ideal.
What are your longterm goals?
What motivates you in your life?
Well,
my mind,
what motivates us,
that's I think fairly strict.
All sorts of motivations.
But I mean,
nate,
major motivations.
I like to figure out what the hell is
going on and communicate it.
You know,
I really,
I believe that I've done my best to
actually pursue the truth and,
and it's so useful.
It's so useful.
It's so fun to communicate to people
because one of the things I see,
and this is gonna be fun.
So when I talked to the audience,
it's so cool because lights go on it.
That's really fun.
So when I see that all the time,
if I really communicating to an audience
because someone,
people like that and then the nod and
you think yes,
right?
Or a bunch of connections,
just throwing stuff together.
Then the person got a little blast
that's like turning on lights,
you know.
And so that's fun.
That's fun.
So that's my longterm goal,
man.
Turn on lots of lights.
Yeah.
What motivates me in my life.
I would really rather than things
couldn't get as bad as they could.
So that's motivated me
since like 19,
I don't know how long,
19.
80.
Probably because it was in the height of
the Cold War,
you know,
and things did not look good and I just
started to read about the history of the
20th century.
God
so terrible.
And like I would just wrap it up in
half.
It seems unnecessary.
So whatever I could do to make that even
somewhat less likely to happen again,
that's fine.
That's fine.
And I don't question that
because it seems so wrong.
You know,
I remember the story that really stuck
with me and there was this story about,
you know,
our switch was a big city basically,
it was a huge place and one of the
things that gardens used to do was when
the people were unloaded,
you know,
they were separating families and
anybody who didn't look like they were
going to be useful to do a bunch of
useful score before they died would be
just sent off to the gas chambers.
And so that's pretty
imaginative and uh,
but that wasn't bad enough,
you know,
because if you did survive
even after having lost everything like
that,
then there was always the opportunity to
purchase you with useless work.
So one of the tricks of the guards was
to make people pick up a sack of salt.
We are 100 pounds and carry it from one
side of the camp to be up and then back.
Brilliant,
brilliant.
You know what evil is an aesthetic and
it has a sense of humor.
I mean,
the sign over Auschwitz read work will
make
great.
That's a joke by the way.
It's like the mutual assured
destruction.
The geopolitical idea in the 19 sixties
and fifties was mutual assured
destruction.
When you launched your weapon,
you're done,
you're done.
There's nothing left in the afternoon is
math.
It's like that's a joke.
It's a joke,
but it's not funny and you know that's.
That's a place where you see the art,
the archetype of evil,
urge in the midst of the geopolitical
debate to emerge from the pit,
so to speak,
in your job like that,
and then to retrieve.
It's not.
That's the thing.
Worth the fight.
We should decide someone.
When do we stop?
One more question.
Okay.
How do you compromise making it?
Are you becoming successful while being
true to yourself and not falling into
the system?
Pretty question.
That's an existential question.
By the way.
The reason I framed it that way just
because it's an eternal question.
I think that's the question that human
beings have always had to face no matter
when,
no matter where,
because the system is always corrupt.
It's always corrupt.
That's an archetype stuck to the old
dead evil and the reason it's corrupt.
There's two reasons,
one is it started with Dave and because
it's lighting behind the present and the
future,
so it's,
it's just design for the wrong era.
That's part of it and they never part
is.
People aren't updating it because they
were willfully blind tartar away,
but,
and so now if you align with it too
tightly,
then you risk becoming a carbon copy of
that.
But by the same token,
the thing is it's one side who's upset.
So this is a really important thing to
learn.
He first he is the culture is that the
tyrannical cane,
but it's also the vice kate and at the
same time,
and you know,
you're obviously the press by the
University of Toronto,
but you know,
here you are and so you're unbelievably
privileged at the same time you're being
torn apart and that's exactly what it's
like to live within a culture.
You know,
you're lucky if you're lucky,
if all that's happening is that you're
not being torn apart because the typical
tyrannical system,
all it does is to create a lot.
It doesn't do anything good for him.
At least you can sit here and relevant
piece and say what you want lights are
on and it's warm,
you know,
so that's actually pretty good.
So the first thing you have to
understand is that you need to be
grateful to the system.
It's given you everything.
Now it's taking away a lot too.
But that's just like,
yeah,
that's the existential issue is games
with one hand and takes away with the
other.
So the trick is how to not become
corrupt by identification with the
system.
It's how to balance balance gratitude
with the,
with the awareness and the desire to
make change.
And that actually is being represented
in religious thought in many ways.
So with the ancient Egyptians,
for example,
they,
they represented the system with the god
or Cyrus who was old and blind and and
likely to fall under evil influenced and
the different dog named horace who is
the art of Egypt,
you know,
and horace.
His job was to see evil because I'm
serious,
was blind to it.
And then to enter into combat with it,
even though that's very difficult,
and the horror said,
one of his eyes,
pour it out when we did that.
And then to go bring your side of the
stack.
The death basically will.
That's what you're supposed to do.
You're supposed to you,
you've got an old dead came
and your job is to pay attention.
See where things are not right.
Fix it.
And if you do that,
then you can align yourself with the
positive element of the culture while
you're simultaneously act as the living
corrected to its accesses.
And you can do that.
Here's one way to do it.
You could start new university.
Well one is don't write things you don't
believe.
I would also say this is where you're
supposed to challenge things.
University.
Don't act like you believe things don't
bleed.
No,
because.
And it happens.
You're not going to fight about the
culture.
You're going to find 100,000 micro
battles with the culture.
And you have to decide with each micro
battle what you're going to do.
And it's really important.
So I can give you an example.
So let's say you go to work and there's
a bone there because there will be and
the boy comes into your office and you
have 10 seconds to make yourself make it
clear whether or not you're going to be
bullied.
That's all 10 sentence because he's
going to figure it out that well.
So how,
how have you been in not being bullied?
You have to transform yourself into the
sort of person that isn't going to be
bullying and the bullies will figure
that out right away and he'll go find
someone easier to pick on him and you
win and you'll hardly even notice.
So
if you continue to fight against,
if you continue to fight,
yeah,
and I'm wait and colorful way
against things that we didn't press you,
but it will become strong and if you
become strong but you won't be co-opted
into the evil of the system.
And a lot of that has to do.
The Egyptians have this right?
The mesopotamians had the same idea.
They're gone.
They're chaos.
Eliminating God had eyes all the way
around it's head.
Whereas the Egyptians just worshiped
the.
I naturally we're thinking about,
because I don't think you fight
corruption with rationality and
intelligence.
There's no correlation between
intelligence and conscientiousness by
the way,
so it's not a moral,
so what our moral faculty,
it might be a discriminating factor,
but it's not an olfactory attention.
That's what you fight against.
Corruption.
You Watch,
you pay attention because paying
attention means I'm willing to see
what's happening and if something
happens that you find objectionable and
you know what to do about it and you
could do it and you would do it,
and that's about it.
We feel you should engage in that
invasion right down there because that
made you start the system.
It's Michael Michael Challenges.
Stop the system from degenerating into
corruption and actually that's not a
theory.
You already know that if you read the
Gulag archipelago.
One of this things that social hits and
does is say,
okay,
how did the Soviet Union developed into
something that ate its own children?
That's his question,
and what he said was
people lied about everything all the
time.
They so they would claim to be happy and
satisfied with.
They were terrified and angry and they
were micro decisions,
you know,
it's like little things like big lie now
happily for three hours to get bread.
Now that's not a great example,
but.
But I can't.
I'm sorry.
I can't conjure up a great example right
at the moment.
The bullying example is not a bad one.
And then I guess the other thing would
be it's associated with the ideal.
So if you're an idealist to make things
better,
then you put that above whatever else it
is that you're doing.
And if you're offered the opportunity to
engage in something corrupt for short
term material gain or even to avoid
conflict,
you shouldn't take it.
You should say no,
but you have to be ready.
Say No and I don't think you'll be ready
to say no unless you know what the
consequences are.
Not Said No.
Does our,
you'll get weak.
Things will go downhill,
they'll get worse and worse,
and then you'll start.
You'll,
you'll be increasingly motivated to
start hurting people.
So if you don't want to go there,
then when you're offered the chance to
build their own little bit,
don't go there and you have to be
terrified because the thing is going to
be conflict,
right?
If you say no about something,
first of all,
if it's a moral request,
you were exposing the corruption of the
person who's making the request and
they're not going to be happy about
that.
And the second thing is you have to
engage in some cars like that's not
pleasant.
So you've got to think what's going to
fortify you enough to do that?
And that's easy.
All you have to do is know where the
hell you could end up.
And if you really know that,
if you really know it,
you have man,
I'm not going there.
I knocked go there and if it means we
have to have a bit of an argument for an
hour,
no problem,
no problem.
And you'll find it's pretty cool.
It's what you'll find is that people
just don't know that much about those
sorts of things.
They just don't come and do that to you
because it just doesn't work.
They'll go find someone who's either
corrupt,
but you know you have to know the
difference and you have to want to know
and then then you can do it.
I think you could do it because I think
that I think the truth is more powerful
than deception and I think the good is
more powerful than evil and I really
mean that.
I think evil and deceit are weak and so
big.
How could they withstand the truth?
How would that even be possible?
The truth is reality.
How do you withstand reality?
Have a sad reality.
It just rolls over you and so people who
are devoted towards malevolence and he
used deception,
pathologists to relationship with being,
you've got to be strong.
If you do that,
it's not probably possible.
It's like you're driving a rickety car
across a really bumpy landscape,
so
thank you.